you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business colonel these are
dangerous people
season two is clear to go fire uh three
two what are you guys doing what
well you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me
this is a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do
it that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
can i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so oh
for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth
harley although that isn't an open
invitation for you to cough without
covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell am i
supposed to know you're the leader
you're supposed to be decisive
and i've decided that you should eat a
big bag of dicks but this whole beach
was completely covered in dicks
and somebody said i'd eat every dick
until the beach was clean for liberty i
would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do
what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've gotta freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
[Music]
for us
[Music]
you